[Applaudissements]
à
vous souvenez teint 1999
you are my clip de demon cultissime pour
ma génération
ces deux minutes 28 de roulage de pelle
et une des deux bouches cédera geek sa
star du porno des années 90 ça vous
revient c'est beau hein
ces deux minutes 28 d'érotisme très lent
en gros plan voilà pourquoi je vous dis
ça pourquoi je suis là moi très
clairement je ne porte pas de chemise
j'ai pas fait d'école de commerce je
monte pas encore mass start up
j'emploie encore moi le terme d'after
work qui me donne de l'eczéma
quand je l'entends en revanche moi mon
truc c'est que j'ai rouler des pelles
[Applaudissements]
pas mal de paix pas assez pour en faire
un métier
apparemment largement assez pour que
michel lévy provençal me propose de
venir en parler devant deux mille huit
cents personnes ce soir je sais pas
comment je dois le prendre michel voilà
moi mon truc à moi c'est de prendre le
temps de vivre des émotions plus ou
moins lingual plus ou moins réussies
avec des mecs qui ressemble plus ou
moins à l'intervenant précédent du coup
il va merci de prendre le temps de
laisser décanter ses sensations avec ou
sans vin blanc avec ou sans
antidépresseurs ça dépend de la qualité
du produit consommé coucou hugo merci
puis d'écrire sur tout ça est de venir
en parler à des gens sur scène et de les
faire rire a priori c'est un processus
lent ce qu'il faut imaginer que de la
soupe de langues à 2h du mat avec
chemise grise tout bourré jusqu'à une
parole intelligible drôle payante via un
gap et un process de sublimation par
l'écriture et le lexomil en fait le
thème de ce soir le sio ça me fait
évidemment penser à ma première boum
d'ancêtres des after work
et à ma première pelle l'ancêtre de la
chlamydia
et moi ma première tél c'était à 13 ans
à la boum de ma cousine avec julien
moulin ce vous le connaissez
c'était une catastrophe une catastrophe
parce que les premiers contacts
érotiques sont souvent très désagréable
et dégoûtant vos enfants sont en plein
dedans messieurs dames 1 pourquoi parce
que parce que parce qu'une langue ça
bave une haleine ça pue il ya cette peur
ancestrale de l'herpès labial qui rôde
et puis l'enfer de cette attente c'est à
dire que deux minutes 28 coller à
quelqu'un qui a ses propres odeurs et
son propre monde intérieur si riche
soit-il
ces longs jusqu'au climax de l'appel
qu'on attendait tous je sais pas si vous
vous souvenez de cet enfer hormonal de
tout ce que ça faisait en ou d'être
collé à quelqu'un en moi collée à julien
mulas j'avais les mains moites le coeur
en pls le cerveau lubrifié de trop de
malibu coco un pantacourt araki de
mauvais team monde trop de parfums amor
amor dans le coup les stroboscopes qui
me donnait envie de gerber - 13 ans
j'étais pas draghi que ce à quoi mme
julia mulas non plus aux mains car le
pauvre il était sous perfusion de balès
depuis 17h avec tous ses copains plus ou
moins débiles plus ou moins bourré
d'acné de bagan et en bas vous avez tous
les mêmes déodorant axe sens et leur
offrir une espèce de virilité citronnée
ouais non une boum à présent c'est comme
un jeudi soir à oberkampf c'est un
endroit où vraiment les odeurs sont très
prononcé
et les cui un de moins bon pourquoi je
vous dis ça je vous dis pas que c'était
mieux avant je paie une vieille réac en
train de dire que thunder et les
fast-foods sexe ont tué le game de
l'amour dans le fast food j'adore les
sexes non pas du tout c'est juste que
bon à l'époque tout vibrait fort quoi
pendant ces deux minutes 28 qu'était le
slot et le baiser langoureux
c'était un espèce de temps hors du réel
où on prenait le temps de s'accorder
mon désir on angoisse et mon amour était
aligné coeur qu cerveau je les dis dans
l'ordre que je veux il était avec julien
mulas et moi ça me manque ça julien
mulas ne me manque pas il est devenu
expert comptable à blagnac pour rien au
monde je me reconnais à lui non mais ça
me manque
ce temps cette cette lenteur émotionnel
pendant les deux minutes 28 de ce lot
j'ai l'impression même comprend
tellement plus le temps de faire un team
building en interne détroit parce que
c'est hyper chiant le t1000 et que du
coup on prend toutes nos décisions avec
ce petit binôme magique homme ou femme
d'ailleurs un de ma génération
le cerveau nous sert à géolocaliser
toutes les langues dynamique
célibataires du coin célibataire
disponibles et le sexe se charge de tout
le reste
moi cette partie là de moi pensent que
je suis en open relationship avec tous
les barbus plus ou moins sympathiques du
canal saint martin ouais ça fait du
monde mais j'ai du temps et le coeur on
l'a un peu mis sur mme ute quoi passer
25 ans on a pris tellement dans la
tronche des ruptures des ruptures des
ruptures c'est un peu triste mais on
s'est un peu zippé quoi on ouais c'est
comme ça c'est triste c'est le cynisme
c'est le maquereau nisme le coeur on lui
a mis une petite carapace une petite
armure de protection en forme de mini
tub pour se protéger des histoires en
demi molle ouais j'ai dit ah bah en tête
tokoin ouais ouais
c'est pas de ma faute c'est pas de ma
faute michel quand il m'a invité à trois
semaines il m'a dit oui ce soir
j'aimerais que tu sois un peu là claude
lévi-strauss de la tob je comprends
mieux maintenant pourquoi pourquoi je
dis ça je dis ça parce que 13 ans 25 ans
même combat
on est les mêmes à l'intérieur bien sûr
moi j'ai remplacé le malibu coco part du
chardonnet parce que je suis une grosse
bourges mais sinon rien n'a changé on
est les mêmes c'est juste qu'on prend
pas vraiment le temps de les écouter de
dézipper le dos attention je suis pas en
train de dire qu'il faut prendre le
temps de vérifier si tous les crapauds
se transforme en prince non tout ce qui
est visqueux n'est pas bon à prendre en
bouche non je dis juste que c'est lent
parfois très violents d'apprendre à
aimer c'est très lent pour qu une
intimité charnelle deviennent de l'amour
très long pour qu'une sexualité devienne
épanouissante
est ce qu'on trouvait répulsifs et
dégoûtant à 13 ans on a appris à le
pratiquer et à l'aimer mais parce qu'on
a pris le temps et moi je trouve que ce
temps il est dans le roulage de pelle
c'est une éducation sentimentale de deux
minutes 28 donc moi ce que je vous
propose
messieurs dames
c'est de prendre le temps chaque jour de
vous rouler des pelles deux minutes 28
par jour sait rien qu'on sera tous
beaucoup plus de namasté quoi
merci